c'est l'heure de la reprise pour l'as
poissy les joueurs pc qui s'entraînent
tous les soirs de façon intensive sous
l'oeil de l'entraîneur laurent fournier
objectif préparer physiquement la saison
prochaine et surtout peaufiner les
automatismes entre les joueurs à
l'intersaison le club a enregistré cinq
départs pour cette arrivée
les recrues c'est ce qui nous manquait
la saison dernière je crois qu'on a misé
sur la cohésion de groupe
elle a envie de se surpasser ensemble de
faire une belle équipe pour pour pouvoir
rivaliser avec les avec les meilleurs
pour faire partie des meilleurs le club
compte également sur clément chantôme
l'ancien joueur au 249 match avec le
paris saint germain a signé au club en
janvier dernier je sors d'un cursus
professionnel où j'ai fait quinze ans de
de foot pro là je deviendrai un club
amateur donc moi c'est de prendre du
plaisir et c'est de faire partager mon
expérience aux plus jeunes et essayer de
faire grandir le club
après avoir terminé à la 13e place de
national de l'année dernière à la limite
de la relégation le club espère faire
mieux cette saison déjà faire plaisir à
notre public faire plaisir aux gens qui
nous aident comme comme monsieur le
maire qui nous est quand même énormément
dans ce club
donc à un moment donné il faut leur
faire plaisir à ces gens là et je dis à
mes joueurs c'est pas open bars et moi
je suis comme ça je suis un combattant
je considère qu' on n'a rien sans rien
donc voilà aujourd'hui ambitions 5e à la
10e place allons-y pourquoi pas et si on
est 11e et avec super un super état
d'esprit c'est ça qui m'intéresse
le premier match de la saison est
programmé le samedi 22 août à domicile
contre blois l'un des plus gros budget
du championnat en cas de victoire l'as
poissy lancerait parfaitement sa saison